to celebrate our 100th episode we are
lucky enough to be joined by a no doubt
illustrious guest he was not easy to
find but through our state-of-the-art
daily wire technology we are going to
speak with Michael from the 200th
episode do we have him let's bring on
future Michael Michael Michael is that
you
[Music]
Michael Michael
yep Michael it's me it's me from the
hundredth episode I can't hear you that
well how much coffee did I smoke Michael
Michael you're not dead Michael Michael
I am you from the hundredth episode are
you are you doing some kind of shoot for
the 200th episode did you think should
be rode let you get to it I guess I'm
not the only one puffing on fifth no or
you make it to 200 episodes what do you
mean I didn't make it to 200 episodes
are you Oh Michael
oh you stupid swarthy loud you thought
you made it your stupid sketches you got
a podcast about politics we wanted to
hear about politics and culture and
history
you are his stupid sweaters and his
stupid bowtie looks like he looks like
the feet is cutting out
looks like the feeds cutting out
Marshall Marshall looks like